You were always the smart one. The kid
who got it quickly, who didn't have to
try, who teachers
adored. You're so gifted, they said. And
it felt good. But now something feels
off. Here's what no one tells you. Being
labeled the smart kid isn't just a
compliment. It's a trap. When
intelligence becomes your identity, you
build your entire self-worth on
something that should be a tool, not
your definition. The real problem isn't
that you've lost your intelligence.
It's that you never learned how to be a
beginner. When your sense of self is
built on effortless achievement, you
develop a brittle self-concept that
shatters the moment you face genuine
challenge. So, you avoid situations
where success isn't guaranteed. Not
because you're lazy, but because you're
protecting your very identity. This
disconnect between who you were told you
are and how life actually works is why
you feel lost. But understanding this
pattern is your first step to freedom.
What if the discomfort you've been
avoiding is exactly what you need? What
if your fear of not being naturally good
at something has been keeping you from
becoming exceptionally good at anything?
You weren't just meant to be
exceptional. You were meant to be whole.
And that journey from fragmented
brilliance to integrated selfhood,
that's the true potential you're here to
fulfill.